in a blender put team chickpeas cumin  seeds paprika and turmeric and blessed  to a paste  [Music]  next we'll spinach in olive oil and chop  finely then add to the chickpea mixture  sprinkle in gram flour made from finely  ground chickpeas then shave golf ball  sized chunks of the mixture using a  spoon and rest in the fridge when ready  to cook heat oil in a frying pan shallow  fry the koftas until golden brown on all  sides then rest them on kitchen paper to  absorb any excess oil for an easy  dipping sauce mix yogurt with $1 Botta  heaney and a squeeze of lemon and stir  in freshly chopped coriander a  mouth-watering dish that's perfect for  sharing chick feed cumin and spinach  kofta with tahini dressing  until deliciously soft these small  beings come dried or in tins and there  are great cheap ingredients to make  dishes more subs that knock on the heat  take your fix and sort of place them in  gently